we're really excited to be here I'm
Robert and this is Stephanie
we're both grad students at UC Berkeley
and we're gonna tell you about ray which
is a project we've been working on
together along with a number of
collaborators both at Berkeley and
outside of Berkeley so ray is an open
source system for writing parallel and
distributed Python applications and it's
specifically designed to support machine
learning workloads so distributed
computing comes up all over the place in
machine learning and these new workloads
are stressing are pushing the limits of
existing systems so much so that machine
learning researchers and machine
learning practitioners are not using
existing standard distributed systems
instead they're often building new
systems entirely from scratch for each
new application that they're working on
and alphago from deep mines and DOTA
from open AI are two good examples of
this but there are many examples um so
there's a lot of redundant engineering
effort right now in machine learning in
fact uh deploying a machine learning
application often requires machine
learning practitioners to spend a lot of
time engineering systems to be
distributed to be more performance to be
faster to parallelize code and things
like that
so I'm gonna tell you more about what
raised what Ray is what we're building
how we're trying to solve this problem
and Stephanie will dive into the
technical details of what ideas we
needed to use to build a scalable and
distributed in fault-tolerant system so
here's a high-level depiction of what
we're building ray is the underlying
distributed system and it also hosts a
number of libraries on top that support
the different components of the machine
learning ecosystem this this list is by
no means exhaustive but these are
examples of standard components that
appear over and over in many machine
learning applications I'm going to come
back to this slide but first I want to
contrast this with the existing picture
in the machine learning ecosystem so
here's what it looks like today when we
think about machine learning we often
think of training machine learning
training so this could mean taking a
deep neural network and training it to
recognize objects and images it could
mean training a reinforcement
learning agents - to play Atari games or
to solve some other tasks of course
training is only part of the picture
once you've trained your model you need
to take that model and do model serving
in other words use the model to generate
predictions or actions in production and
of course hyper parameter search is
another standard component of machine
learning the machine learning lifecycle
this means essentially running multiple
experiments with different
configurations to find the right
settings of the configuration and
they'll see you need to in order to run
these experiments you often need data
you need to load that data from
somewhere process the data transform it
feed it into your application and that
data may come from a streaming data
source as well so all of these boxes
represent computational patterns or
components that appear in in many
machine learning applications and today
each of these components is implemented
as a standalone distributed system so
here are examples of different
distributed systems for these specific
components you have tools like horev odd
and distributed tensorflow for training
you have tools like vizier for hyper
parameter search MapReduce and Hadoop
for data processing things like that and
the this is great these systems are all
very powerful very specialized and very
good at what they do but this poses a
serious challenge for applications that
are cross-cutting and want to integrate
many of these different components
within a single application so as soon
as you want to start having a tight
coupling between training and serving
and and data ingest and all of these
things in a single application then
you're either gluing together a number
of existing systems or you're taking the
approach that a lot of people take which
is to just throw all this away and build
a new system from scratch for your
application um so what we're working on
is trying to take all of these these
components which today are standalone
systems and Riaan reimagine them as
libraries on top of a single distributed
system so here we're building ray which
is the underlying distributed system
along and we're also building these
libraries on top which support the
different components of the machine
learning lifecycle now
it's already you know really interesting
and really valuable to be able to do
each of these boxes individually but
what we're excited about and where a lot
of the potential really comes from is
being able to enabling applications that
integrate all of these different
components together and enabling new
things that are difficult to do today so
this is a picture of what we're working
on and now I'm going to describe the
different abstractions within Ray so at
the highest level of abstraction we have
a set of libraries targeting the machine
learning ecosystem some of these are
already fairly mature such as our
libraries for hyper parameter search and
distributed reinforcement learning
others we're working on right now and
you'll notice all of these libraries
have very different computational
patterns very different systems
requirements and performance
requirements so it's difficult in order
to support these on top of a single
system you have to have a very general
and flexible and expressive underlying
programming model it would be difficult
to support all of these on top of a
single system like a dupe which targets
a specific computational pattern so to
get expressivity and generality we have
an underlying programming model based on
tasks and actors this is essentially
taking functions and classes right which
are two core concepts and programming
languages and translating those into the
distributed setting so we provide the
ability to take arbitrary functions and
execute those remotely and
asynchronously as tasks and we provide
the ability to take arbitrary stateful
objects or classes and instantiate them
as services that you can talk to through
a certain API so I'll say more about
what the API looks like and how you use
that in a real-world example in a second
but this is where the the expressivity
and the generality is coming from
underneath the programming model we have
a back-end which which handles things
like scheduling failure handling object
transfers resource management and these
kinds of tasks and the the the core data
structure that the backend reasons about
is
dynamically constructed graph of task
dependencies and Stephanie's going to
talk more about how we make that
scalable how we implement that and what
the challenges there were so before I
dive into the API I want to mention that
raisin open-source projects we're
developing this on github and it's a
fairly young project but it's growing
quickly the green line indicates where
we had our first release about a year
ago and we just really we're working on
0.6 right now we have a growing number
of contributors both inside and outside
of Berkeley and this is a this includes
substantial contributions from companies
using ray so we have an increasing
number of production use cases and one
use case I want to highlight is from ant
financial in the upper left corner so
ant financial processes a substantial
chunk of the of the financial
transactions that happen in China and
they've used ray to build a a tool or
system for detecting money laundering
and other forms of fraud so the
interesting thing here is that it's a
very complex application you have a
streaming transactions coming in which
contribute to building up a graph of
financial transactions and you need to
be able to dynamically query this graph
and the previous iteration of this tool
they had before using Ray required
stitching together three different
distributed systems to implement the
functionality they needed and they were
able to use ray to consolidate that down
to a single distributed system so this
is one of the kinds of applications that
becomes easier when you have a
general-purpose
underlying system okay so now I'm going
to tell you a little bit about what the
API looks like so here are two regular
Python functions those specific details
don't matter we can take we can add this
ray dot remote decorator and now if I
invoke one of these functions so I call
zeros dot remote what that does is it
submits a task it generates a task which
is handed off to the back end which
schedules it on some machine and assigns
it to some worker where it'll execute
asynchronously and eagerly and the
actual function invocation that you're
running in Python this Xero's remote
call will return immediately
and without blocking and that will
return this ID one object which is a
future or an object ID remembers that
representing the eventual output of the
computation now if I submit another task
then that will then these two tasks can
execute in parallel because there are no
dependencies between these tasks and
this picture on the left hand on the
right hand side is a depiction of the
the data structure that the backend is
keeping track of so the the white
circles are tasks and the the blue
squares are represent the the outputs of
those tasks and as you can see there are
no dependencies between these tasks we
can take the futures that are output by
these two tasks and pass them as inputs
into a third task and that constructs
that defines an implicit dependence of
the third task on the first two tasks so
the third task won't the dot task won't
actually be able to execute until the
first two tasks have finished although
the three lines of Python that you're
actually writing will return immediately
so you run these three lines that
constructs this graph and then as the
object dependencies become available the
tasks will execute and if you want to
block and wait for the computation to
finish and retrieve the results you can
call Rea dot get to do that this will
block and then actually return the
output of the task so if you're familiar
with composable futures this is this
should look fairly familiar it's a very
powerful abstraction and it lets you
build scalable applications pretty
easily out of the box one thing this
doesn't do is it doesn't let you share
mutable state between multiple tasks and
that's actually very important for
machine learning mutable state comes up
all over the place it could be the state
the weights of a neural network it could
be the state of some simulator it could
be some encapsulation of some
interaction with the real world and so
to encapsulate States we are using an
actor abstraction so here's a Python
class it has a it's just a toy example
it has a counter and it has a method for
incrementing the counter like before we
add this
remote decorator and now when we create
one of these counter objects what that
does is it starts a new process
somewhere in the cluster with this the
counter object States and method
invocations on that object translate
into tasks that are executed assigned to
the counter actor and executed on that
actor and like before these tasks return
futures you can invoke multiple tasks
and each actor task is implicitly
dependent on the one that executed right
before it and these tasks actually share
the state of the counter process and can
mutate it and like before you can call
rate get to actually block and retrieve
the results of the computation so these
are two different abstractions you have
tasks and actors but they actually under
the hood they're all working on top of
the same dynamic task graph abstraction
and mutable State is encoded in the
graph abstraction and these things are
very interoperable it's not the case
that you either use tasks or actors and
this as in a Python you use both
functions and classes together here you
can compose these things together they
can be nested within each other and
there are a lot of different they
interoperate pretty seamlessly so now
I'm going to give you an example of how
you actually can use these I'll just
show you on my laptop you can use these
tools together to implement an actual
interesting example so if you're
familiar with the term parameter server
this is comes up in machine learning and
distributed training you have the setup
is you have one or more parameters
server processes and one or more worker
processes here a parameter server is
essentially a key value store it holds
the weights of a machine learning model
for instance the weights of a neural
network or the coefficients of a linear
model and the workers run in a loop
where the workers each have some data
and they compute updates to the model
and send those updates to actually
update the parameters and then they get
the latest parameters and then they just
run this in a loop so a parameter server
is something that's typically
implemented and and shipped as a
standalone system kind of like a
database or
a key value store but here we're
implementing I'll show you how we can
implement a parameter server as a simple
application in a few lines of Python on
top of Ray so let's see so I'm going to
start up Python and hopefully this is
large enough and going to import ray and
then I'll call ray dot init which starts
the relevant ray processes that includes
a scheduler and an object store
Stephanie's going to talk more about the
architecture in a few slides so if you
were this is on my laptop but if you
were running on a large cluster this is
the only line that would be different ok
so I'm going to import a few things so
now if I were to define a parameter
server as a Python object this
essentially it needs to have some
parameters so we're going to just
initialize as parameters to a vector of
zeros for simplicity and then it has a
method for getting the parameters
getting the latest parameters and in
this case that's all we're going to do
is return the parameter vector and it
also needs to have a method for updating
the parameters which will take some sort
of gradient update and then we'll there
are a lot of different update rules you
could use here but what we're going to
do is just add the gradient to the
parameter vector so now to translate
this into the distributed setting we can
add this remote decorator and now if I
I'm gonna try to move the bottom of the
screen up a little bit
okay so now if I were to actually create
one of these objects that's what that
does is that's starting a new process
somewhere in the cluster and then method
invocations like if I call a get prams
dot remote that sends a task off that
runs on this process and returns a
future and if I want to block and
retrieve the results that's I can call
rate get which is yeah which is that's
actually retrieving the output okay so
that's the in this picture that's
starting one of we've just started one
of these parameters server boxes these
processes so the next thing we want to
do is start some workers so I can define
some worker tasks which are essentially
they can just be functions which take a
handle to the parameter server and
they're gonna do they're just going to
run in a loop so maybe we'll do a
hundred iterations they're gonna do
three things they're going to get the
latest parameters compute a gradient
update and then send the update to the
parameter server so to get the latest
parameters it's just a matter of calling
ray dot gets on the parameter server get
params and then we're going to compute a
gradient update here I'm just going to
make up a pretend gradients but this is
where you would use tensor flow this is
where you would use the data that you
also have available to actually compute
the gradients and we'll say that takes
some small amount of time and then we're
gonna send the update to the parameter
server okay so this defines the worker
tasks now we can start up a few workers
and pass in a handle to the parameter
server so here I'm starting three
workers and then if we go back and
actually get the parameters you can see
they're being updated in the background
so what we did here is we going back to
this picture we started some workers and
and wired them up to communicate with
the parameter server so now we have some
parameter servers and some workers and
they're talking with each other and the
exciting thing here like I mentioned is
that a parameter server is usually
something that is implemented as a
standalone system and here we're able to
recreate a toy
version of that in a few lines of Python
and one thing that gives us is a lot of
flexibility by being able to implement
the parameter server at the library
level or at the application level if we
want to configure it differently say we
want to shard the parameters across
multiple parameter servers we can just
start up multiple copies of this actor
or if we want to switch from synchronous
training to asynchronous or vice versa
or if we want to change the update rule
about how we update the parameters or
handle stragglers differently or or any
other number of you know why are thing
the communication of differently it's
just a matter of these are all a few
lines that need to be changed in the
application itself so that's one example
of the kinds of benefits you can get
from by moving things from this sort of
system level to the library or
application level so now Stephanie is
going to tell you more about the backend
and the ideas we had to use to build
such a scalable and fault-tolerant
system thanks so very so here's the
dynamic tossed graph which robert showed
in the earlier example and i'm going to
show how we can actually execute this on
a system so I'll start with the design
for a single node and eventually we'll
scale this up to a cluster so the each
node has a scheduler which is
responsible for scheduling tasks in the
graph according to their data
dependencies and we also have a couple
worker processes so here these are
Python processes that are just waiting
on a loop to be assigned tasks the
scheduler might decide to assign the
first series tasks since it doesn't have
any data dependencies and the work will
begin executing this task once it's
completed it can store the return value
of the zeros tasks in the object store
so it talks to this object store there's
one per node it talks to the object
store directly to store the input and
output values of each task we also have
a global control store which you can
think of as a fault tolerant key value
store which holds all of the system
metadata so in this case that might be
the objects locations for all the
objects in the cluster it also includes
what's known as the lineage of a piece
of data
so here the lineage is
the subgraph of the dynamic test graph
which describes for a given object what
tasks were required to create it so here
the lineage of the object that we just
created is just the zeros task so the
scheduler would write this to the global
control store and as we'll see soon this
is important for fault tolerance so next
if we want to scale this up let's say
that we now have multiple notes that all
look identical we want to make sure that
there are no bottlenecks in the system
so that we can scale up and get
increasing performance with every node
that we add to the cluster so these
nodes might execute tasks independently
so this third node might execute the
other zeros tasks and store the second
object in its own objects store it might
write that location to the global
control store and also the lineage of
the other zeros tasks
so these schedulers can talk to each
other directly in order to transfer data
from one node to another and they can
also forward toss from one node to
another and so that lets us implement
policies for better load balancing and
also to optimize for things like data
locality so I won't go into too much
detail here but two of the key decisions
that we made for scalability is one that
we made are we have a fully
decentralized dag scheduler so this is
scheduling the dag the dynamic task
graph of data dependencies and we also
have a sharded key value store so we're
very careful to make sure that the
global control store doesn't become a
bottleneck and we make sure that every
operation touches only a single key so
just to walk through a simple example of
how we actually schedule a Tusk
let's take the third task in the graph
the dot task
so here the driver which is the process
that's creating all these tests submits
the dot task to its local scheduler and
that scheduler logs the task to the
global control store and we do that so
that we have the full lineage of the dot
task again this is for fault tolerance
so I'll show that in a few slides
so now let's suppose that the scheduler
decides to forward the dot toss to
another node and I might do that for
instance because that node already has
one of the dependencies available so
that node will see that it only has one
of them so it has to retrieve the object
data for the other dependency and I
would do that by asking the global
control store for the locations
the other object and it can then request
the object data directly from the other
node and receive the value in its own
objects store so now all the data
dependencies are available so the
scheduler can assign the toss to one of
its workers and that worker will return
the value a that returned by the dot
function inside the object store where
you can now retrieve it with Reigate
okay so this sort of shows the flow
during normal execution but what happens
when there's a node failure so in R a
one of the goals is to be able to
support both long-running jobs and also
jobs that can scale up to many many
notes so node failure is inevitable here
so now let's suppose same example except
before we were able to transfer the
object data to the node that needed it
the one that had it failed for some
reason so now this is bad because we
don't have a copy of that object
anywhere in the system but we need it in
order to execute the dot task so we can
do here is actually rely on the lineage
that was stored in the global control
store so this is a pretty classic idea
what you can do is just walk the lineage
of the dot tusks and see which
dependencies are missing and then replay
any of the tasks that we need to produce
those those objects so here we can reax
acute the second zero says just by
assigning it to one of our local workers
that worker will return the value object
to inside the local object store and now
we can assign the dot toss same as
before so we're able to fully react
scute just by reacts acute asingle tasks
so what's really nice about this
technique for fault tolerance is that
recovery can be really fast and that's
because you only have to replay the work
that was actually lost so in that
previous example we only lost the data
object - and we only had to reiax acute
one TAS in order to get it back before
we could continue executing on the other
hand this actually adds significant
overhead to normal execution and that's
because you have to do this extra work
to record the lineage of each task so
this is the part where you're actually
logging the lineage that dynamic test
graph to the global control store and
you have to do that during execution if
you want to be able to recover and as
I'll show in a few slides
actually important that you do this this
commit so you want to make sure that the
TAS lineage will survive in case there's
a failure you have to do that before the
toss actually starts executing if you
really want to make sure that you only
have to replay a minimum amount of work
so this is one example of a key
trade-off in systems design where you
actually have this trade-off between
fast execution when there are no
failures versus getting fast recovery
when there is a failure so another
alternative technique that shows the
opposite end of this trade-off is
actually a global checkpointing so in
that method you don't log any of the
lineage at all during execution instead
you just take a global checkpoint across
all the workers in the system so that
means you're adding minimal overhead
during execution on the other hand once
there's a failure even if it's just a
failure of a single node you end up
having to rollback the entire system to
the most recent global checkpoint and
that in general if you have a very large
cluster and a long-running job that
might actually end up wasting a lot of
significant work so in the past because
of that trade-off lineage reconstruction
techniques have been really successful
in supporting applications that have
coarse grain tasks and what I mean here
by coarse grain is tasks that run on the
order of seconds so you can think of
here of big data processing systems like
spark or Hadoop where they're really
worried about getting high throughput so
the latency for a single task doesn't
matter so much but for the applications
that were targeting we're actually
looking applications that have a high
throughput of many fine grain toss so
these might run on the order of
milliseconds and that includes
applications that robert mentioned like
stream processing graph processing
interactive queries and also intend
reinforcement learning applications so
all of these applications have a large
number of tasks per second that each run
on the order of milliseconds and the
reason that milliseconds thing is
important is because if you think about
an application where each of the tasks
takes only a millisecond to run but then
you have a system that's adding maybe 10
milliseconds of scheduling delay per
task that's already a 10x overhead
that's just added by the system so the
goal for the rest of the talk is to see
whether array can get both fast task
execution when there are no
failures as well as fast recovery when
there are failures so this is kind of a
rhetorical question but so yeah we're
gonna show first why previous lineage
based solutions end up being slow when
there are no failures so that's to
demonstrate the trade-off that I
mentioned earlier next I'll show how ray
actually avoids the execution overhead
that we see in these previous solutions
and finally I'll show the benefit that
we see for ray applications okay cool so
in previous solutions the main technique
for correctness so being able to recover
from a failure is just to commit the
lineage first so first we'll see we'll
walk through an example and see what
happens if we don't do that so now we
have a lineage storage at this hop which
is the global control store from a few
slides ago and this is a fault-tolerant
storage system where you can write a
tasks lineage to this storage system and
guarantee that it won't be lost if
there's a failure at the bottom we have
two independent notes each of which is
running their own scheduler and we're
going to submit a simple application to
the first node so this is just two tasks
one of them dependent on the other and
we're going to begin by committing the
lineage to the global storage but here
we're not going to wait for that commit
to finish so we're going to try and
schedule the second test immediately to
the other node which accepts it for
execution and now what happens is in the
case of a node failure you're not going
to be able to recover completely so here
if this first node dies normally what we
would do in lineage reconstruction is
walk the lineage of the second task but
now that lineage is actually here we
never wrote it to the global storage so
it's not available anywhere in the
system and so that means now the second
node actually can tree execute its task
or I can't execute its task at all and
the system can't make progress so the
solution here is pretty simple which is
just to wait for that commit to happen
first before you schedule the second
task so here we want to wait for the
lineage storage to accept the tusks and
then we wait for an acknowledgement back
that the task has been committed so now
it's safe to schedule the second task so
the remote node
which accepts it for execution and now
let's see what happens if that first
note dies well because we know that the
the lineage has already been committed
we can retrieve it from the lineage
storage and now the second note can
continue to make progress so this is
just a simplified example but the main
point to show here is that you have to
pay this round-trip to the global
storage system before you can execute
the task so that's on the critical path
for task execution and this might not
seem like such a big deal but if you
think about it you're actually having to
do this fault-tolerant right to a remote
system and this is also represents a
bottleneck in the system so if we have
for instance a very high toss load at a
certain point in the system we're gonna
end up adding a increasing queuing delay
at the lineage storage system and that
means increasing queuing delay for every
toss that we execute so the goal in ray
is actually to try and get predictable
performance for task execution so we
want to try and avoid any bottlenecks at
least on the critical path for tossed
execution and just sort of defer this
step to later on in the execution so the
idea is pretty simple you just commit
the lineage later but now the main
problem is is being able to guarantee
correctness now that you no longer have
this sort of centralized source of truth
so instead we'll now have a lineage
stash at each node which you can think
of as an in-memory sub graph of a global
dynamic toss graph and we're gonna use
this to guarantee correctness so now
instead of writing the lineage first to
the global storage system the first node
will just write the lineage to its own
stash which is really fast because this
is just local memory and now it's safe
to forward the toss to the remote node
but this time instead of just forwarding
the toss we also forward along with it
any uncommitted lineage so that's any
lineage and our local stash that hasn't
been committed in the global storage
system yet this SAS will add the lineage
or the other node will adds a lineage to
its own stash and then accept the toss
for execution so here you can see we've
basically taken that step to the global
storage system off the critical path
instead the only message that we're
using is the
NIDA to forward the toss from one node
to another and we can actually now
commit the lineage to the global storage
system in the background and this is
mostly so that we can keep the size of
the stash small so now if we look again
at what happens when there is a node
failure we can see that because we
forwarded the uncommitted lineage before
now the second node can retrieve the
lineage from its own stash and continue
executing the graph so basically what
we've done here is get the total number
of steps required in terms of the number
of messages required down to the minimum
of just scheduling the toss from one
node to another but we have this added
benefit of being able to guarantee the
same correctness as if we committed the
lineage first so I'll show next the
benefit for applications so here we have
a distribution of latencies so this is
the latency between toss submission and
then toss execution and I'm measuring
this in a simple application where we're
just forwarding a bunch of tasks from
one set of nodes to another in this case
it's at a rate of 2,000 tasks per second
per node so here this is the version of
Ray without any fault tolerance at all
so what I've done here is basically just
turn off lineage logging completely and
it just forwards the toss immediately so
this is really the minimum required in
order to execute a graph and you can see
here that the latency is actually really
predictable you have a relatively small
tail and all of the tasks complete
within tens of milliseconds so that's in
contrast to the design that I showed
earlier where you have to commit the
lineage first before you schedule the
task so I'm showing three different
curves here where I'm increasing the
rate of toss mission from sort of half
the speed of the earlier one to the same
rate so even at the lowest rate of toss
submission you can already see the gap
in latency between the version without
fault tolerance versus the one with
fault tolerance and as we increase the
rate at which we submit tests you end up
getting arbitrarily high latency and
that's because the this sort of central
storage it becomes a bottleneck so what
we've done here is we got fault
tolerance but we had to trade-off
latency
during normal execution in order to get
it but what we do in the lineage - is
actually show that you can get both of
them together so what I just did was add
a curve on to this graph that actually
exactly overlaps the version that
doesn't have any fault tolerance at all
so we're essentially getting fault
tolerance for free we got the same
latency as if we didn't do any logging
at all but we're actually able to get
fault tolerance if one of the nodes dies
we can always recover it okay so today
Robert and I presented ray which is the
system for writing parallel distributed
Python applications and it's meant to
unify the ml ecosystem and I gave a
brief overview of how ray
enables fault tolerance so that you can
get both fast recovery without when
there are failures and also fast
execution when there are no failures at
all thank you we'll take any questions
[Applause]
yeah yeah so you do have to do a little
bit of extra work in order to make sure
that you can clean up the stashes at
every node but the point there is that
you can well so there are two things one
of them is that it's not necessarily to
actually write the tasks you only need
one of the nodes to do that and the
other thing is that you can also scale
up the global control storage but the
point here is that like you can actually
get consistently low latency
no matter what the current throughput of
the storage is one of the nice things
about this design where you have
separate schedulers and separate a
separate metadata store is that you can
scale these things independently we
should also cheer so the question was
basically when you have this more
decentralized algorithm whether you end
up having to do more work possibly on
the global control storage because now
you have to commit the lineage at
multiple nodes there are multiple
policies that you can take to make sure
that only one node writes the lineage
like a simple one is just wherever the
test was submitted you just write it
there
so does that answer your question or
yeah
right yeah yeah that's right but the
point is that so
there's the latency of sending the
initial message which you have to pay
anyway and now like what you're doing is
adding the amount of data that you have
to send over but that data is relatively
much smaller to sign up compared to the
lancia of live initial message yeah in a
way so you can think of the lineage as a
log it's just a very structured log
where we know that it's a dag yeah all
the way in the back
right so I think you're asking sorry the
question it was how do you know what
other nodes are free and so you can this
is sort of a question about scheduling
policy which we're not really gonna
cover in this area mostly because like
you can say a little bit right yeah I
mean so we the goal there is to
basically mimic a centralized scheduler
with decentralized scheduler and so some
of the things that you can do are
basically passed around resource
information between the nodes so that
each of the nodes can make decisions on
their own and then there are there's
like some extra work that you have to do
to make sure that you make a good
scheduling decision since now you're
working off of still information but we
can talk more about that offline if you
want because each node has a slightly
stale view of the entire system we don't
assume that we make perfect scheduling
decisions up front it's possible to make
bad scheduling decisions but then we can
always correct for them and tasks can be
can be moved back or spilled back to
other machines if the load on a given
node is too high yeah
so we do have an example so the question
was we mentioned horev odd for
distributed training as an example of a
system that could become a library so we
do have an example of distributed
training and implementing primitives
like I'll reduce on top of Ray in these
cases we are we are absolutely still
using existing deep learning framework
so whether that's tensorflow or PI torch
or something else we are not building
our own deep learning framework but we
are treating them as essentially a
single node libraries that do and we'll
we in that case we let tensorflow handle
distributing computation across multiple
GPUs within a single machine and we use
ready to coordinate the scheduling and
data transfer across machines yeah
so the question is what if you have a
single task that wants to use all the
GPUs that absolutely is the case for for
things like tensorflow
and we've let each task the user can
specify the resource requirements for
each task so you can say this task
requires 8 GPUs or whatever and then
then it is we don't and then it's up to
the the actual function or you to tell
tensorflow to actually use those 8 GPUs
but will do things like set the CUDA
visible devices and other variables like
that yes yeah so which parts are written
in which languages so most of the code
is in C++ and actually if we look at
this yeah this picture so the object
store the scheduler are all in C++ the
global control stores implement is just
using a collection of Redis servers
which is an in-memory key value store
the workers are Python processes and
they but there's a client library
implemented in C++ and we also have Java
workers that can implement that can so
we can have a Java front-end or other
because the whole system is language
independent and the data layout we use
is actually language independent as well
we're using a data format defined by
this Apache Aero project which is
essentially a really exciting project
that lets enables using shared memory
between all of these processes with
without D serialization so one thing I
didn't mention is but the object store
allows all of the workers read the same
memory read the same objects through
shared memory and don't have to create
their own copies or serial or do
expensive D serialization so that's an
important performance optimization
especially on large machines and and we
have libraries mapping Python objects to
and from the aro format and we're also
one situation that a lot of
people have is that a lot of production
code is written in Java but a lot of the
machine learning ecosystem is in Python
so right now we're working on enabling
cross language function invocations and
stuff like that to to better support
this use case where you have you know
you're streaming or production code in
Java and you want to invoke a lot of the
machine learning stuff you have in
Python does that answer your question
any other questions
all right yeah it's a it's the question
is the shared memory within a node or
across nodes it's a single machine
shared memory as opposed to distributed
shared memory and that's actually
something we developed originally as
part of Rea and if since contributed to
the Apache Aero project because it's
something that makes sense as a
standalone or is useful independent of R
a great I think we can take any other
questions offline so thanks a lot
[Applause]